this is a production of cornell
university
and today i will talk about
the orienting function
in
nutrition nutrition quality improvement
and
also our recent funding about the oil
gene function
potential function in
creating climate resilience growth
so first i'll introduce the orange gene
function proper nutrition improvement
and for carotenoids
and also uh our recent finding about the
org regulates chromoplastic division and
then our in briefly introduce our
efforts to
increase pertinoid
stable carotenoid accumulation in seeds
finally i'll talk about our recent
findings in
the critical law or orange gene
in photosynthesis
so uh i'm a researcher associated in dr
lilly's lab so our live manner works on
proper nutrition
so orange green were first cloned in
cauliflower
so in california it's a transportation
insertion which caused a different
splicing of orange gene and finally can
induce chromophores formation and a huge
amount of tertiary accumulation in
cauliflower curves
later we find that in melon
a golden smith is responsible for the
carotenoid accumulation
like cantaloupe we
in our market
so
which also contains the golden sniff
this balancing caused
amino acid substitution changing from
arginine to histine so that's all his
gene
so we find that work is being
responsible for the
induction of common cluster formation
so in recent years
several other groups also find that
origin is associated with the major
qtl
of
personal accumulation like in sweet
potato in carrot and also in cassava
so those
origin may contain different kind of
mutations which also responsible for
high amount of
accumulation so this makes origin a
very good candidate for the crop
nutrition improvement
by breathing
so we all
we are live and also other lab also use
origin as a
tool to manipulate the characterization
by over expressing or nanotubers
can increase chronic carotenoid
accumulation
we also introduced orange in tomato
normally in tomato at the
early early stage the tomato protein is
totally a green but when we introduce
oil gene it can
induce permafrost formation and personal
recognition at the very earliest stage
also
by introducing or in combination with
the personality biosynthesis enzymes
we can
get high level of customer accumulation
rights
so with the
with the advancement of the genetic
of the christopher castaneda to know
editing method
in future we hope to
precisely edit the origin to our keys in
different kind of crops to finally
introduce improve the crop nutrition
content
so
as we all know that plastics are
essential plant organelles which
are different types of plantar plastics
including the
aminoplast which is the main site for
the
starch accumulation and also the
chloroplast is the
site for photosynthesis and the
chromopods
is a male cycle carotenoid accumulation
we find that with
or or mutant or histine there is only
one or two large chromoplasts in one
cell
but in tomato there are many chromos
which
which lead to a high level of
carbohydration
so when we
do the or or his calories
in our business we
finally can still
induce chromoplast formation but only
one or two large chromoplasts in one
cell
so we are thinking that that's the
limitation of the carcinoid improvement
we are thinking that if we can increase
the chromosome number so we can increase
the characteristic accumulation
sync capacity to finally
increase the
calculator level
so we want to figure out that why or
he's
limited as a chromosome division
so we figure we find that
um
when we check the or or white type or
his geology localization in numbering
plastics
we find that we are associated with the
division ring
which is in the middle of the plastic
but in chloroplasts we find that
that's the
localization of are
different in
numbering plastic
so
that implies that or in number implanted
or chrome parts may have different
function in
chromoplast division
so when we do the
z-axis
scanning we can clearly see that or more
concentrated in the
binary fusion site
look like look like in a green
structure
so in our artists we can only see one or
two uh
contrasts
what type of the tested number
is normal
so we so
that's the question is how does or
regulate from plasma duplication we want
to figure out the molecular mechanism
for chromoplastic division there are no
many reports about that but for
chloroplast division it's a well
established mechanism there are
different
rings inner rings other rings that
constrain the
fast
chloroplast and finally the uh by the
binary fusion the chloroplast will be
divided into two separate globe
chloroplasts
so
then we check the interaction between or
his with those chloroplast division
factors and we find that rfs
can interact with r3 which is the
important division factor for
chloroplast division
normally r3 will interact with pr 6 but
with all his final two
x3 it will compete with the pr 6 to uh
to bind up three
so we
proved the interaction by its 300 that
in the
in the absence of orpheus x three can
invert with gr6
but with artists uh three will mainly
interact with four hits
we checked the this interaction by uh
effect
and finally we want to prove the
injection uh in
in vivo so we designed the code minimum
presentation experiment
we stress both uh are both up three in
authoring in both ry type and or his
background
and finally
if we
express r3 or his background
uh after he will mainly find the two uh
or his instead of tr6
so then we prove that uh or his may
interfere the
uh
chat six and upstream induction to
affect chrome classic illusion
so
since we know the mechanism of how are
his affected chrome path division then
we want to correct it to make a uh
chrome plug to make a
small chrome class environment
background so we try to overexpress
different kind of
plastic division factors
the fts z1 z2
pdb1 pdb2 those are all division factors
that affect a chloroplast division
so we want to see that which one can
increase the chromoplast number in or
his background and
finally we figure out that
when we overexpress pdb1 we can increase
the
chromoplast number in or his background
so which makes the
the accumulator
more carotenoids in the in
the
[Music]
complex
so for this this project we figure out
the green plastic especially a chrome
plastic division mechanism which let's
study in previously
and also
this research provide a potential
mechanism to
increase calculator content
by
increase the chromecast number instead
of the biosynthesis
ability
and also uh there are still some
questions we need to answer is
um
what's the major duplication mechanism
for chromecast like in different acros
some from compasses they are transformed
from chloroplasts so they may use
different mechanism some chromoplasts
may develop directly from proplex
plastic
they may use a different
like binary fusion or the
bundling mechanism
and
we only for this study we only had
tested the
injection between prc tx6 and r3 so we
still don't know that there are any more
factors
involved in the in the chromopath
division um
especially when or is not existed
um
then we have we already know that
orchestra is a great greater tool for
carotenoids
for uh calculator
accumulation for crop nutrition
improvement
uh
we also know that the uh
final nutrition content
is
the
availability of the nutrition container
is very important for our our crops
we know that calculus are not very
stable because they have
several double bonds and they are very
easy to be oxidized
especially the
seeds during storage there are the decay
of the carotenoid
vitamin a cartilage the serious problem
so we want to
increase the questionnaire content in
seas additionally we want to
the cartoonizer in seeds are more stable
during storage
so
we
investigated the um traditional
biosynthesis and degradation gene
expression
and
and we have a general idea that we want
to increase the cartilage accumulation
in this meanwhile we want to decrease
decrease the degradation and also
fight against the oxidative stress
in the seeds during the storage
so for this this project we uh
we will target uh several genes for orps
we will uh we target orphes we already
expressed parties to increase the stable
storage of curtain rights and we already
guessed why psy the
phyton synthesis is the bottleneck for
cretinoid of our senses
we want to
increase the psi level and also we need
to knock out the bch2 which is the beta
beta carotene hydroxylase
which can
degrade carotenoid and
additionally we overexpress the hgt
which is for vitamin e biosensors
vitamin e is very important
for antioxida because of its
antioxidant activity
so we want to increase vitamin e level
in seeds
to
reduce the oxidative stress and make
tertiary noise more stable during
storage
so we designed a several construct with
with a bch2 knockout with bcs to knock
out and overexpress guess why
uh
pcs to over extract
psy and also over just workings and
a larger construct
targeted four genes or knockout bch2
overexpressed psy or over express or his
and also over
express http
so the result looks uh
looks looks great so we we observe that
the seeds at the
green stage they already start to
accumulate a high level of carotenoids
when we take close look over the seeds
we will find that
we can already see the chromophase of
formation
in the young seeds and also we did the
carcinoid state stability experiment we
figured out that the
carotenoid
stability
are largely enhanced
because of or image ddt after
eight week storage at 37 degree which
in white house the fertilizer they only
have less than 50 left after after
the stories of this condition
so this
although this experiment is conducted in
our toxic seeds but it can be
adopted for other crops or other
seed engineering to increase the
and catego increase providing a
content
so all these experiments we are talking
about the
nutritional aspect of origin especially
the or his the
mutant version of or
then there are
because oil is highly conserved gene in
green plants
there are a lot of plants they can
then they don't they don't need to
accumulate a
high level of carcinoids in foods or in
flowers or ingredients like carrots so
what's the function of the wild type of
arginine in green tissues so that's
question we always ask ourselves
so
we generate our over expression lines
and for our life double mutant lines of
our lines
and we figure out that
without or let's have a
let's show the pilgrim phenotype
and with the significantly reduced
photosynthesis ability
and when we check the uh chloroplast
structure we find that
the without the origin
the cell called memory stocking is
missing so that makes the chloroplast
cannot function problem
when we do blue network page to check
the
for the senses com protein complexes in
chloroplast we find that there are
several major band missing
in the blue native case
like the light housing complex
assembling the photo system one photo
system to dimer and the
silver complexes for photosynthesis
when we check the proteomic data we find
that
there are many proteins in the light
housing complex are significantly
reduced because the
knockout of oil or lychee
we also
did the
second dimension western blood of our
of the blue native geo of each
lighthousing complex proteins
we find that there are many major
proteins especially lighthousing complex
protein lgb1 b2 they are missing in the
lighthouse and complex assembling to a
large complex
so previously our lab showed that wire
is the molecular chevron of
psy phytonutrient synthesis protein
and that
um
that is the
reason uh or like mutant
left
has less
photosynthesis complex
so when we check the chloroplast closure
of our synthesis pathway
we find that or or like our mutants can
accumulate
photoperforin line which
is the intermediate overclock of
chlorophyll biosynthesis
normally we will not see proto49
accumulation in white high plants in all
in other
calgarian mutants
except for the
enzymes directly convert the proto499 to
mechanism for protoprogramming
so uh
this result
indicates that
in or or like double mutants not only
the
uh cartoonish biosynthesis
is impaired the chlorophyll biosynthesis
is also affected
so we checked that
because or is the molecular chapter we
check that if or also function function
as a molecular chemical
chlorophyll of our senses enzymes and
finally we
figure out that or directly interact
with the methane mechanism kelly test
server unit eye
so mechanism collectors is several
enzyme complex
there are several subunits chli chld
and the csrs which is also named account
file
we confirm that our directory attack
interacted with chli
then
we checked the protein stability we
figured out that in
uh or like double mutant um
the
stability of
chli and psy
is affected
so they'll turn over it very quick
and then when we check because the uh
magnesium intelligence is the sub
multiple subunit
enzyme we check that if we our eye
assembling is also affected
or reluctant latter in oral or life of a
mutant
chli cannot assemble into larger enzyme
complex
then uh since a wire is a molecular
chevron it can protect the protein from
denaturing
so we check we check that if we use a
higher temperature
which may
cause faster protein degradation
previously people report that chli can
be significantly affected by higher
temperature stress
so
when we do the heat stress treatment we
find letter when we over expression uh
or when in the or over expression line
chl i and psy
should show the
higher stability than y-type
and then when we do the enzyme
activity i said we find that
when we treat the magnesium collected
magnesium calcium
with a higher temperature
so the
the enzyme without or show the lower
activity compared to the enzyme complex
with or
we've got a similar result with psy
in our overexpression line psy showed
highest activity but in
our double mutation line the psy
activity was significantly reduced
so
that makes us
think about that or may regulate both
carotenoid and chlorophyll both
carbonite and chlorophyll are
photosynthetic humans
so the right amount and right content of
those photosynthetic pigments are very
important for the proper function of
plants
so
we
we generated our over extraction line
and also we have a one way station in
tomato line
we did a heat stress treatment we find
that
our overexpression line
in our boxes
showed a
higher thermal tolerance
so when we check the pigment content we
figure out the access
our over orientation lines the pigment
content are
less affected by the heat stress
so the similar phenomena will also
observe in
or or expression line tomato
so
over illustration line manual when we do
his treatment we find that
um
the or over expression line uh flies are
less stressed because they are
accumulated less as a signing and
signing up
is a kind of indicator of the
stress response so the wide type of
tomato leaves
they accumulate a
large amount of entertaining
also the
female content both chlorophyll and
carotenoids they are also less affected
in
tomato or overlapping lines
so
for this
experiment we figure out that or is the
master regulator of both
chlorophyll and cartilage are sensitive
pathway
and
or the chakra of the
first committed steps for carotenoids
that's psy vitamin synthesis
for uh chlorophyll of our synthesis or
the structural
cli which is a part of a mechanism
killer case
so as a chaperone or protect both
pathway and against the
stress condition
so
um that will remind us that the function
of our in
natural resistance to antibiotic stress
so actually there's
there are already several reports about
the or over expression or in uh to
increase the planetary resistance to a
biotic stress
but the mechanism is still unknown so
our star this study provided a mechanism
explanation of why or can
increase the planar aerobiotic stress
resistance
so finally
we conclude that
or
can not only function as
in the crop nutrition improvement
by manipulation or
expression it can
be a good candidate for the crop for
generated the climate resilience crops
to increase the plantar resistance to
antibiotic stress like heat stress
so that's the
my talk today
thank you for our lab members and our
collaborators this work is funded by
usgirs funding and the new funding i'd
like to take any questions
thank you
um
yeah that's a good question because uh
that's possible that uh
uh curtinoid
can provide procurement for ava so abm
might affected
the planetary system to stress
conditions
um
so uh we already so that's just one part
of our uh
just one part of our explanation of our
chaperone function
and
for our y type over expression we didn't
see the huge
increase or huge uh
improvement of curtains so that might be
not the main reason of the
anti-strength or anti-antibiotic stress
of our function
what is
[Music]
um for this experiment and science we
just used the kind of uh
stress indicator so in many kind of
stress conditions that we will see the
as assigning accumulation
so for this part we just indicated that
plants are less stressed
so we didn't see the direct connection
between carotenoid or exocyanin
but in
in fruits like apple foods there might
be correlation between
as a signing and cartoon recommendation
that's out of the scope of our this
study
yes um for your i think second project
when you talked about um over expressing
over his and the chromos division factor
um how did the science of those double
mutants compare to the like single big
chromoplasts that you had in the or his
overexpression lines
um if you go back to this slide
i can't remember the name of the gene
um
actually we increased the chromosome
number yes
how did the science of the
the
higher number
compared to
the science of wild type or only or his
mutants
um
is this site on this side
um for
we overexpress the video we want to make
small chromoplasts
so the number i increase
so the science is comparable to the wild
type chromecast
science then
yeah the the
size is comparable to the
to the
so for our cases only contain one large
contrast but uh i think there's a
balance between the size and the number
yeah so you cannot get a larger size and
a lot of some a lot of compass but for
this project for for this
example we observed the
increase of chrome cluster size but the
uh increased from some number but the
size are not
comparable to the or his ever you know
or he's just a one large compass
and
we also observed the size that were
slightly affected by the
by the orientation of x3 and we did i
didn't show you in this slide
good question
thank you
when you're counting and measuring
chromosomes
and studies do you assume that any
plastic containing continues
in performance class or are you
identifying the scenes from a platform
so
because we are using the uh
we are using the color system so in
under the light microscope we can
clearly see the
chrome class like like this one
so um
yeah we can we can clearly see the
contrast instead of so for other type of
classes like the amino plus or the
even procrastinator you can hardly
observe on the light microscope but for
chrome plus it's easy to
observe under the light microscope
thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu